[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من الخرطوم
واشتباكات باسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه في مدن
العاصمه السودانيه
الثلاث الى نيام ومظاهرات جديده للمطالبه
برحيل القوات الفرنسيه من النيجر على وقع
توتر متصاعد بين قاده الانقلاب
وباريس والى بغداد ومن هناك دع رئيس
الوزراء العراقي مختلف الاطراف السياسيه
في كركوك الى الحفاظ على السلم
الاهلي وفي مواضيع الحصاد في هذه
الليله مع اعلان وصول صواريخ بريطانيه
فرنسيه بعيده المدى كيف تعلن اختراق خط
دفاع روسي جنوبا وتكشف ان اسلحه النيتو
ستستخدم في القرم زيلينسكي يقيل وزير
دفاعه ويتحدث عن حاجه لنهج جديد في
الميدان وموسكو تعلن تعزيزا لمواقعها في
دونيتسك على وقع اشتباكات باسلحه ثقيله
وخفيفه في مدن العاصمه السودانيه الثلاث
الجيش السوداني يقصف مواقع الدعم السريع
في نيالا جنوب دارفور البرهان يجري
محادثات في بورت سودان مع حاكم اقليم
دارفور ومناوي يشدد على اهميه تنفيذ اتفاق
جوبا للسلام في
السودان مع انتهاء سريان اتفاق ينظم
الوجود العسكر الفرنسي في النيجر مظاهرات
في العاصمه نيامي تطالب برحيل القوات
الفرنسيه وباريس تقر ان قواتها في النيجر
لم تعد قادره على القيام بمهامها وتتمسك
مجددا بابقاء
سفيرها في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا تداعيات تاكيد كيف
تقديم تعهدات مكتوبه بعدم استخدام اسلحه
النيتو على اراضي الدوله الروسيه المعترف
بها دوليا لكن ستستخدمها في شبه جزيره
القرم تطلعي ارائكم بهذا الشان كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما هي
تداعيات تاكيد كيف انها ستستخدم اسلحه
النيتو في القرم وجاءت النتيجه الى الان
كالتالي
57% توقعوا ردا روسيا ميدانيا عنيفا على
اوكرانيا بينما راى 28% ان الخطوه
الاوكرانيه من شانها اشغال القوات الروسيه
في شبه جزيره القرم اما 15% فاعتبر ان
هناك تباينا بين كيف والنيتو بشان اولويات
الهجوم
المضاد هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على
الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل
عربيا
ودوليا وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في شمال شرق سوريا تمدد المعارك من دير
الزور الى الحسكه والرقه وحلب في ظل قلق
امريكي شيخ قبيله العقيدات ينفي وجود هدنه
وما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تتعهد
بملاحقته اذا اعلنت كيف ان الاسلحه
المقدمه من النيتو ستستخدم في جبهه شبه
جزيره قرم ترافق ذلك مع تاكيد وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني ان فرنسا وبريطانيا
زودت بلاده فعلا بصواريخ بعيده المدى من
جانب اخر قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها
تمكنت من اختراق خط الدفاع الروسي الاول
في منطقه زبروجيا جنوبي البلاد في هذه
الاثناء اعلن الرئيس زيلينسكي عن تعيين
روستوم اوميرو وزيرا جديدا للدفاع وقال ان
هناك حاجه لما اسماه بنهج جديد في الميدان
لصالح من يلعب عامل الزمن في الحرب دائره
رحاها في اوكرانيا والصيف قارب على
الانتهاء تاتي الاخبار من الجنوب وتحديدا
زبروجيا محمله بمعطيات تقدم اوكراني نوعي
ان تواصل قد يقلب معطيات الساحه هناك وقد
يكون له فعل الدومينو باعتبار قرب
المقاطعه من اخريات لا تقل اهميه مثل
خيرسون وشبه جزيره القرم اختراق بشكل حاسم
لخط الدفاع الاول لروسيا بالقرب من
زبروجيا تنقل تفاصيله الجارديان
البريطانيه عن الجنرال اكسندر تنافسك قائد
مجموعه القوات العمليات والاستراتيجيه في
الجنوب الاوكراني خصصت وفقه روسيا لهذا
الخط نحو 60% من وقتها ومواردها العسكريه
لتشي وتحصينه لكن كيف تم الاختراق يقول
ترنسكي انه تحقق بعد اسابيع من اعمال
ازاله الالغام معربا عن توقعه تحقيق مكاسب
اسرع مع الضغط على خط الدفاع الثاني وهذا
خط اقل تحصينا خصصت له روسيا نحو 20% من
مواردها العسكريه والامر نفسه لخط الدفاع
الثالث مستبعده تمكن الاوكرانيين من تجاوز
الخط الاول مسؤولون اوكرانيون صرحوا اكثر
من مره قائلين اذا سقطت ميليتوبول فستن
هار الدفاعات الروسيه باكملها وصولا الى
خيرسون وستقف القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
مباشره الى الحدود مع القرم بدات كيف في
تقدمها تستفيد من كل الامكانيات المقدمه
لها من الحلفاء خاصه المعلومات
الاستخباريه الخاصه برصد تموضع القوات
الروسيه وقد يكون لافته في هذه الظروف
حديث وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني عن تزويد
فرنسا وبريطانيا اوكرانيا بالصواريخ بعيده
المدى تساعدها في الهجوم المضاد على نحو
قد يعجل بانتهاء الحرب بينما قال وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني انهم لن يستخدموا اسلحه
النيتو في اراضي روسيا المعترف بها لكنهم
سيستخدمونها في القرم استراتيجيه كيف
جنوبا تراهن بدايه على استعاده ميليتوبول
وعينها ابعد من ذلك فهي البوابه الى شبه
جزيره القرم فضلا عن انها تقع على نقطه
تقاطع طريقين سريعين مهمين مع خط سكه حديد
تستخدمه موسكو لنقل افراد ومعدات عسكريه
تحاول ايضا القوات الاوكرانيه في هجومها
المضاد الوصول الى بحر ازوف لقطع الطريق
بين القرم والجبهه الشرقيه وكسر الهيمنه
الروسيه على شواطئه وياتي هذا عاقبه تقدم
حققته قبل ايام على محور اوري خوف وانتهى
الى اختراق دفاعات القوات الروسيه في
الجنوب واستعاده بلده روبوتي و جنوب
زبروجيا لكن هل سينجح سيناريو الاختراق
فيمضي الى نهايته في الثام عشر من اغسطس
الماضي قالت واشنطن بوست ان تقييما لاجهزه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه رجح فشل الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد في الوصول الى ميليتوبول
بسبب استخدام روسيا حقول الالغام والخنادق
وقال محللون ان الطريق ميليتوبول واعره
للغايه واستعاده المدن القريبه مثل توكماك
تشكل صعوبه بالغه والسؤال لا يتعلق فقط
بما اذا كان الاوكرانيين قادرين على
اختراق خط او خطين دفاعي لكن هل يمكنهم
الذهب ابعد من ذلك وان يكون لهم ما يكفي
من القوات لتحقيق الاهم وهو دفع القوات
الروسيه الى
القرم انضم الينا من اوكسفورد فرانك ليدوي
كبير الخبراء الع عسكريين في مؤسسه جلوب
سك للدراسات مرحبا بك سيد فرانك في الوقت
الذي تتحدث فيه كيف عن تحقيق اختراق نوعي
في الجبهه الجنوبيه جبهه زبروجيا في الخط
الاول من خطوط الدفاع الروسيه
هناك تاتي كيف لتغير وزير دفاعها وتتحدث
عن حاجه لنهج ميداني جديد ما الذي يعكسه
تعكسه هذه الاقاله في ظل هذا
التطور
طب مسائكم اولا نعم انه امر له دلالته
ريزنيكوف والذي كان وزيرا
للدفاع تم ازاحته من منصبه من قبل الرئيس
زيلنسكي كانت هناك شائعات تفيد بذلك قبل
بضعه ايام وشائعات قويه في شهر
فبراير كان السبب مزاعم بوجود فساد في
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بديل السيد
رازن كوف هو شخص مهم جدا فهو
روستم
اوميرو والذي هو من اصوله من جزيره القرم
وهو ناشط
فعال في الدفاع عن قضيه شبه جزيره القرم
اذا نحن
لدينا تركيز واضح على كون شبه جزيره القرم
على اساس انها مركز ثقل الحرب الاوكرانيه
سيد فرانك اذا هذا العنوان تكرر في الطرح
الاوكراني ولكنه كان اكثر وضوحا في هذه
الايام بخصوص استهداف شبه جزيره القرم مع
تزويد فرنسا وبريطانيا لصواريخ بعيده
المدى
لكيف مع هذا النهج الجديد وهذه الاقاله
ووزير دفاع جديد في كيف ما الذي
سيتغير لكي اكون صادقا معكم اعتقد ان
العمليه سوف تستمر تقريبا بنفس النمط اي
بعباره اخرى ببطا او ابطا مما توقعه
الاوكراني لكن كما اشار تقريركم قبل قليل
الصواريخ
التي وصلت خاصه صواريخ تورس من المانيا
سوف تحدث فرقا في القدرات لانها اطول مدى
وبامكانها ان تضرب شبه جزيره القرم وهي
توفر خيارا اخر
اضافيا
ل مقارنه
بالصواريخ ستوم شادو البريطانيه والفرنسيه
اذا هذا خيار اخر يضاف الى الترسانه
الاوكرانيه وتجم تجعلهم قادرين اكثر على
تعريض شب جزيره القرم للخطر من وجهه
نظرهم شكرا لك من اوكسفورد فرانك ليدوي
كبير الخبراء العسكريين في مؤسسه جلوب سك
للدراسات شكرا على المشاركه
معنا افاد مراسل الجزيره ان الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تبادلا القصف
المدفعيه والصاروخي في وسط وشرق ام درمان
كما شهدت نياله ومناطق في جنوب دارفور
مواجهات بين الجانبين في هذه الاثناء
التقى رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان اليوم ح حاكم اقليم دارفور
مني ارك مناوي في بورت سودان لمناقشه
التطورات في الاقليم وقال مناوي انه بحث
تنفيذ اتفاق جوب للسلام في السودان وان من
المهم تنفيذه على اكمل وجه لضمان استدامه
السلام حسب
تعبيره فرص انهائها تتضاءل
الحرب المشكه على دخول شهرها الخامس لا
تمنح الحسم لاي من الطرفين بل لم يحقق اي
منهما مكاسب عسكريه واضحه نشدان تلك
اللحظه يزيد من استعار القتال على جبهات
عده تتبادل قوات الجيش والدعم السريع
القصف المدفعي
والصاروخي وبما ثقل او خف من السلاح يشتبك
الطرفان في مدن العاصمه السودانيه الثلاث
الخرطوم الخرطوم بحري وام درمان تتحدث
مصادر طبيه عن مقتل ما لا يقل عن 25 شخصا
معظمهم مدنيون في معارك الساعات ال 48
الاخيره 20 منهم وبينهم اطفال قضوا في
غارات جويه استهدفت حي الكلاك السكني
جنوبي الخرطوم على ما ذكر ابناء المنطقه
ولجان
المقاومه يتحدث الجيش السوداني عن تعارض
احياء عده في ام درمان لقصف عشوائي من طرف
قوات الدعم السريع من جهه الخرطوم بحري
ومنطقه الصالحه الجيش نفسه يواصل من جانبه
قصف تجمعات الدعم ومناطق ارتكازه في
العاصمه وكما هو شان العاصمه تتواصل
المعارك ضاريه في شمال كردفان وجنوب
دارفور ماساه
سمع رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
بعضا من تفاصيلها من حاكم الاقليم مني
اركو مناوي وقبلها كان البرهان قد التقى
في مدينه بورت سودان ايضا وفدا شعبيا من
ولايه غرب دارفور برئاسه السلطان دار
المساليت سعد بحر الدين الشاهد على معارك
الجنينه ومقتل الالاف هناك انه واحد من
تجليات حرب تتعثر الجهود الاقليميه
والدوليه في انهائها يحاول الدعم السريع
التسويق لرؤيه قائده لحل سياسي شامل لدى
المؤسسات
الاقليميه الرؤيه التي لم تخرج عن مبادرات
وخطط طرحت سابقا لم تلقى ترحيبا في
السودان من قواه السياسيه الرئيسيه ومجلس
السياده
الانتقالي رئيس المجلس عبد الفتاح البرهان
كان قد قال لدى تفقده معسكرات الجيش في
ولايه كسله ان الحرب لن تنتهي الا بالقضاء
على ما سماه التمر الاخذه قوته في التناقص
ما لا يتناقص في السودان المازو هي معاناه
سكانه المحتاج نصفهم للمساعده الانسانيه
بحسب تقديرات امميه شردت الحرب اكثر من 4
ملايين سوداني وبين انعدام الامن الغذائي
الحاد والافتقار للخدمات الاساسيه حوصر من
بقوا في الخرطوم
وضواحيها تؤكد الامم المتحده انها لم
تتلقى سوى ربع وعود التمويل
وتقول منظماتها انها تواجه عقبات لا حصر
لها لنقل
المساعده قال سعد بحر الدين سلطان عموم
قبيله المسالي في ولايه غرب دارفور ان ما
شهدته مدينه الجنينه من انتهاكات واسعه
واعتداءات على ممتلكات المواطنين وارواحهم
تقف وراءها قوات معتد محترفه ولها تدريب
متقدم على الاعتداء على الناس واكد بحر
الدين الجزيره في نشر سابقه ان التحقيقات
وتقرير الامم المتحده يشيران الى قوات
الدعم السريع وانه يؤكد ما ذهبت اليه
للمزيد ينضم الينا من لندن عمران عبد الله
مستشار وقائد قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان سيد عبد الله مرحبا بك معنا كيف
ترد على هذه الاتهامات التي اكدتها تقارير
الامم المتحده وهو السلطان المساليت قبيله
المسالي في غرب دارفور يتحدث عن ذات
الامر
طيب في الب السلام عليكم ورحمه الله لك
التحيه استاذ سلمى ولكل مشاهدي قناه
الجزيره اهلا بك التقارير نعم استمعت
للتقرير وصراحه ل ما تفضل به السيد
السلطان سعد بحر الدين شيء يعني مؤسف
للغايه لان السلطان سعد بحر الدين لو كان
صادقا فيما يقول هو الشخص الوحيد الذي
يمكن ان يبرئ ساحه الدعم السريع من هذه
الاتهامات
لان لانه حضر بنفسه الاجتهاد المجهودات
التي قام بها السيد قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو في ذات الوقت من
العام الماضي واقد عدد عدد خمسه اكثر من
خمسه مصالحات ما من بينها حتى مصالحه ما
بين قبيله المساليت والقبائل العربيه ايضا
في تلك الفتره يعني مكس القائد الاعلى
لقواه الدعم السريع مده شهرين في مدينه
الجنينه والسلطانيه على مزالك ا لكن للاسف
السيد السلطان بحر الدين استخدم القضيه
القضيه الانسانيه كقضيه السياسيه لصالح
حزبه الذي ينتمي له وهو معروف لدى الجميع
السلطان سعد بحر الدين ينتمي لحزب المؤتمر
الوطني وقد تقلد عده مناصب خلال هذا الحزب
فبالتالي هو الان تكيل هذه الاتهامات
ل سعد بحر الدين سلطان عموم قبيله
المساليت ولكنه يتحدث بكل موضوعيه عن
مجموعات مدربه ومحترفه هي من قامت
بعمليات الانتهاكات والقتل الممنهج في ولا
يه غرب دارفور في منطقه الجنينه وهو تحدث
ايضا سيد عبد الله عن ان هذه التقارير اتت
من الامم المتحده وهذه التقارير تحدثت
واشنطن بانها تقارير موثوقه تؤكد ارتكاب
فضاع في تلك المنطقه ما مصلحه كل هذه
الاطراف بما فيها سلطان عموم قبيله
المساليت وهذا المجتمع الدولي وواشنطن ان
تتهم قوات الدعم السريع اذا لم ترتكب مثل
هذه الفضاءات
هناك نحن
نحن لا ننكر انه وجود فزاعات وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه وقعت في مدينه الجنينه ونحن اول
من طالب بالتحقيق في هذا الامر لكن هل
هنالك اي جهه مستقله جاءت وقامت مباشره
عمليه التحقيق لم تكن ايضا ما نتفق معه ان
الجهه التي قامت بهذه الفظائع جهه محترفه
ومدربه وتمتلك السلاح العالي ونحن من
اليوم الاول وجهنا اصابع الاتهام
للاستخبارات العسكريه التي قام بتدريبها
البرهان وفلول النظام سابق تقارير الامم
المتحده سيد عبد الله تقارير الامم
المتحده عندما تحدثت عن هذه التقارير
الموثوقه هي كانت تحدثت نقلا عن المنظمات
الموجوده هناك عن شهادات السكان وكل ذلك
وفق تقارير ومسارات تسلكها الامم المتحده
لتتاكد قبل توجيه اصابع
الاتهام استاذ سلم هنالك عده نقاط لابد من
معرفتها في المقام الاول نحن عندما اشرنا
قلنا ان هنالك جهات مدربه وقامت بهذا
العمل هذه الجهات تم تجريبها من قبل
الاستخبارات وهي ذات القبائل التي ينتمي
اليها معظم
قبائل التي ينهد منها الدعم السري في
ولايه دارفور يتحدثون بذات اللغه يعني
يمتلكون ذات الثياب تم تسليحهم حتى قوات
الدعم السريع الان احيانا لا يعرفونهم
احيانا تحصل اشتباكات ما بينهم اذا من
الصعب جدا ان ان ان المواطن البسيط ان
يميز ما بين الدعم السريع او ما بين الذي
تم تجنيده من ذات القبائل من الاستخبارات
العسكريه الامر الثاني بالنسبه للمنظمات
التي تحدثت عنها وقلت انها موثوقه من اين
اتت هذه المنظمات نحن دعونا ان تكون هنالك
جهه مستقله كل هذه المنظمات الموجوده
هنالك هي تنتمي للنظام السابق نظام
المؤتمر الوطني فبالتالي كل ما تقوله
مردود الى ان الى ان تاتي جهه مستقله تقوم
بهذا التحقيق نحن مستعدين للتعاون معه طيب
ابقى معنا سيد عبد الله سنتذكر بما قاله
سعد بحر الدين سلطان عموم قبيله المساليت
في ولايه غرب دارفور في تصريحاته
نتابع حتى هذه اللحظه لم تدول اي معركه ما
بين الجيش وقوا الشعب السريع وقوات الدعم
السريع في ولايه غرب درور مدينه الجنينه
حتى هذه اللحظه المعارك اللي دارت من قوات
معتد نحسب انها قوات محترفه قوات لها
تدريب متقدم وواد لها مهنيه عاليه في انها
كيف تعتدي على الناس وكيف تستولى على
مقتنيات الناس وكيف تبحث وتفتش البيوت
بشكل انا احسب انه لا يمكن لشخص عادي ان
يقوم بهذه العمليه هي قوات يعني التحقيقات
والاستطلاعات يعني التجرد المتحده كله
اشار للدعم السريع وان اكد ذلك
طبعا استمعت سيد عبد الله لما قاله سلطان
عموم قبيله المثالي سعد بحر الدين الذي
اكد بتجرد بانه يعني يؤكد ما تحدثت عنه
هذه التقارير وفند ذلك على كل محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه فتحت تحقيقا بمثل هذا
الامر هل قوات الدعم السريع مستعده
للتعاون من اجل كشف مثل هذه الفضاءات
ومرتكبيها هذا قد اعلنه السيد القائده
الال لقوات الدعم السريع من اليوم الاول
وحتى قائده قوات الدعم السريع في مدينه
الجنينه دعى بذلك وقال نحن مستعدين
للتعاون ومستعدين ان تاتي اي جهه مستقله
للتحقيق ونحن مستعدين للمسؤول امام المح
وان ثبتت ادانتنا فنحن مستعدين ان نقدم
نفسنا للمحاكمه ماذا اكثر من ذلك لكن هذه
التقارير سيدتي الفاضله نحن لا نب لها
كثيرا لاننا نعلم جيدا ان المنظمات التي
توجد في السودان هي تابعه للنظام السابق
نظام المؤتمر الوطني المواطنين الذين
يتحدثون حتى الذين احيانا يخرجون في
مظاهرات هم اعضاء المؤتمر
الوطني موظفيهم حتى العساكر احيانا يلبسون
الزي المدني ويخرجون في مظاهرات باعتبارهم
مواطنين لتضليل الراي العام نحن نعرف خبس
هذا النظام ظام وتضليله للشعب السوداني
وراي العام فبالتالي كل هذه المسائل لا
تنطلي علينا نحن نطالب بان تكون هنالك جهه
مستقله ونحن مستعدين للتعاون معها بكشف
الحقائق شكرا لك من لندن عمران عبد الله
مستشار وقائد قوات الدعم السريع في
[موسيقى]
السودان الى تطورات المشهد في النيجر
ينتهي اليوم اجل الاتفاق الذي ينظم الوجود
العسكري الفرنسي في النيجر بعدما الغى
قاده الانقلاب حزمه من الاتفاقات العسكريه
المبرمه مع فرنسا بالتزامن استمرت
الاجراءات الامنيه المفروضه على مقر
السفير الفرنسي في العاصمه نيامي بعدما
اقرت المحكمه العليا في النيجير طردى
السفير فورا والغاء حصانته الدبلوماسيه
بعد تقديم طلب رسميا بهذا الشان الى رئيس
المحكمه وكانت الخارجيه الفرنسيه قد اعلنت
قبل ق ايام انه لا يحق لقاده الانقلاب
تقديم مثل هذا الطلب مشيره الى ان اعتماد
السفير يتم بشكل شرعي من قبل السلطات
المنتخبه في
النيجر وكان الاف المحتجين من انصار قاده
الانقلاب قد بداوا اعتصاما يستمر اياما
امام القاعده الفرنسيه في العاصمه اليامي
تلبيه لدعوه وجهتها جمعيات مسانده او
جمعيات مسانده للمجلس العسكري للاحتجاج
والتنديد بمواقف فرنسا ومطالبتها بسحب
قواتها من البلاد كما طالب المتظاهرون
باريس بسحب سفيرها من النيجر واحترام
سياده
البلاد ذا وقال حسومي مسعود وزير الخارجيه
في حكومه الرئيس المحتجز محمد بازوم ان
استعدادات مجموعه اكواس للتدخل العسكري في
النيجر دخلت مرحله متقدمه واضاف مسعود في
حديث لقناه فرنسيه ان هذه الاستعدادات
ليست حربا على النيجر بل هي عمليه لمره
واحده تهدف الى استعاده سلطه الرئيس بازوم
كما استبعد الوزير مسعود ان يلجا قاده
الانقلاب لاقتحام مقر السفير الفرنسي في
نيامي نظرا لمخاطر هذه العمليه عليهم على
حد
تعبيره من جهته قال منسق ما تعرف بحركه 62
في النيجر عبد الله سيدي للجزيره ان
الحركه حريصه على سلميه المظاهرات والحشود
المندده فرنسا وموقفها من النيجر واضاف ان
باريس تبحث عن ذريعه للتدخل عسكريا في
النيجر بعد ان تاكدت من عدم امكانيه تدخل
اكواس فرنسا تبحث عن حجج للتدخل في النيجر
بعد اقتناعها بفشل واستحاله تدخل اكواس
ولهذا قالوا اولا انهم لا يعترفون
بمسؤولين السفير الفرنسي تم طرده وقالوا
انه لن يغادر القوات الفرنسيه ايضا قالوا
انها لن تغادر كل هذا لدفع الشعب ليتصرف
بغضب ويمس بعض المصالح الفرنسيه حتى يجدوا
حجه للتدخل لكن شعب في النيجر ذكي ونحن
اخذنا وقتا مناسبا اكثر من اسبوعين مررنا
فيهما تقريبا بكل احياء يامي لتوعيه الناس
باهميه التصرف
سلميا لذلك قالت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
كاترين كولونا ان قوات بلادها موجو لدعم
مكافحه من سمتها جماعات ارهابيه ولتنفيذ
انشطه تدريبيه واضافت في مقابله مع صحيفه
لوموند ان التدخل الفرنسي في افريقيا كان
دائما بطلب من السلطات المحليه وكلما قل
الحضور الفرنسي هناك زاد انعدام الامن
كولونا اكدت ايضا ان باريس ليست مضطره الى
الانصياع لسلطات غير شرعيه بخصوص سفيرها
وهو باق في نيامه واعتبرت وزيره الخارجيه
ان قاده الانقلاب في النيجر لم يتحركوا
بتوجيه من فاجنر او روسيا بدوره اكد وزير
الدفاع الفرنسي سيباستيان لو كونور في
حوار جريده لوفيغارو وشدد لو كونور على ان
المناخ المعادي لفرنسا في افريقيا وقفت
وراءه روسيا بصفه
كبيره وكان مصدر عسكري في النيجر قد قال
ان القوات الفرنسيه في العاصمه نيام
التزمت بالانتشار داخل القاعده العسكريه
الفرنسيه فقط وذلك منذ الغاء الاتفاقيات
الدفاعيه والامنيه مع باريس في ال8 من
يوليو الماضي وذكر المصدر ان المجلس
العسكري وجه بتسليح الشرطه في العاصمه
والمناطق المتاخمه لها وابقى على حاله
التاهب في صفوف
الجيش المظاهرات ضد فرنسا في شوارع نيامي
مستمره لا تتوقف حتى تبدا من
جديد لكن فرنسا ترفض قرارات المجلس
العسكري متعلقه بالغاء الاتفاقيات معها
وترى ان المجلس سلطه انقلاب ولا يمثل
حكومه نيجر
الشرعيه وتقول ان ضغوطات قاده المجلس على
سفيرها في نيامي لن تغير هذا الموقف بينما
ترقب عن كثب خطواته تجاه بعثاتها
الدبلوماسيه وقواتها المنتشره في النيجر
داب محمد على المشاركه في المظاهرات
والاعتصامات امام القاعده العسكريه في
مطار نيامي يقول ان حركته تبنت المطالب
الشعبيه بمعارض انتشار القوات الفرنسيه في
النيجر قبل ان يقدم الجيش على الاطاحه
بالرئيس محمد
بازوم تلاحظون ان هذه مظاهره سلميه والهدف
منها الغاء الاتفاقيات العسكريه بين فرنسا
والنيجر نحن هنا للمطالبه بمغادره القوات
الفرنسيه ولا حاجه لنا اليها ل امننا هم
هنا منذ امد طويل لكن الوضع الامني لم
يتحسن تتباين مواقف المناصرين للمجلس
العسكري وانصار الرئيس محمد بازوم من
العلاقه مع فرنسا هناك من يعيدون بازوم
وهناك من هم ضد بازوم ولكن انا ارى ان
المشكله ليست ضد بازوم الشارع النيجيري
والمجتمع النيجيري يخاف يخاف من انزلاق
امني خطير قد يؤدي يدمر البلاد سلحت اقسام
الشرطه المختلفه وزودت شرطه المرور في
العاصمه نيامي والمراكز الامنيه في
ضواحيها باسلحه خفيفه ويحث المجلس العسكري
الجنود على اليقظه ويطلب منهم الاستعداد
للتصدي للقوى الامبرياليه التي تنكر على
النيجر حقها السياديه في اداره شؤونها على
حد تعبيره تامل المجموعه الاقتصاديه لغرب
افريقيا ان يتراجع قاده الجيش في النيجر
عن قرار الاطاحه بالرئيس بازوم بينما لا
يغيب سيناريو التدخل العسكري في حال لم
يوافق قاده الانقلاب على اعاده الرئيس
المحتجز الى السلطه على طرفي نقيض يقف
الفرقاء في النيجر من العلاقه مع فرنسا
فبينما يدعم طيف واسع من السكان مطالب
المجلس العسكري خروج القوات الفرنسيه من
البلاد يرى انصار الرئيس بازوم ان بقاء
هذه القوات او
مغادرتها شان تقرره فقط الحكومه الشرعيه
المنتخبه فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
نيامي ضموا الينا من دوسلدورف في المانيا
اداما جاي الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه
ومدير الاتصال السابق في المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول لغرب افريقيا اكوا سيد
ادام جاي مرحبا بك معنا ما
فائده اصرار فرنسا على ابقاء قواتها رغم
ان انتشارها فقط هو في القاعده العسكريه
الفرنسيه وابقاء على سفيرها ايضا بعد كل
هذه الخطوات من قبل المجلس العسكري في
النيجر ما الذي تنتظره
فرنسا من وجهه نظرك
طبعا
هم يحاولون ان يبينوا
بانهم بين ما هو امر قانوني وما هو امر
مشروع يختارون ما يسمونه امرا قانونيا وهو
ان نظام بازوم الذي تمت الاطاحه به هو
النظام الشرعي لانه قانونا كان هو النظام
ولهذا السبب اذا ما سمحوا
لقواتهم وسفير بالمغادره فهذا يعني ان
قواتهم وسفير موجودون بصوره غير قانونيه
وغير شرعيه لكن القضيه هي تتعلق بمساله
الاعتراف والسياده السيطره على النيجر
الان هي بيد قاده الانقلاب وعلى الفرنسيين
ان يدركوا هذا الواقع لكن للاسف السيد
ماكرون سمح لنفسه بان يرتبط اسمه باسم
بازون بشكل اقرب واكثر مما ينبغي لهذا
السبب هو عندما يصر على بقاء سفيره وقواته
انما يخلق فرصا لوقوع نزاع عنيف مسلح لانك
لا تدري شعب
النيجر الان اذا ما دخلوا المجمع الذي فيه
السفير او القوات العسكريه بشكل ما فهذا
قد يخلق حاله اعلان حرب في هذه تذكرون في
العام 78
و79 عندما
الايرانيون اخذوا رهائن السفاره
الامريكيه طيب ما الذي تتوقع ان تكون عليه
اسمح لي نستفيد من الوقت اكثر ولا نغوص في
التاريخ نتحدث عن الحاضر يعني عندما يتحدث
وزير خارجيه رئيس الحكومه المحتجز في
النيجر محمد بازوم يتحدث بان مجموعه اكواس
تستعد للتدخل العسكري في النيجر ودخلت
مرحله متقدمه هل مثل هذا الكلام واقعي مع
المواقف الفرنسيه حتى الساعه المتصلبه
بشان عدم خروج سفيرها وقواتها من
القاعده
القوات
طبعا بازوم هم يقولون ان
بازوم يقول ما تريد فرنسا ان تسمعه وما
تقوله فرنسا ووزير خارجيه بازوم هو ما
يريد ان يوحي بان الكواس تقول ما تريده
فرنسا في حاله الرئيس
النيجيري مثلا قال انه يريد تغيرا
ديمقراطيا كما حصل في نيجيريا في ظل حكم
عبد السلام ابو بكر في العام 99 بعثوا
بوفود ساعدت ساعدت نيجيريا للعوده من
الحكم العسكري الانقلابي الى الحكم المدني
طبعا لم يصر احد على التدخل
العسكري طبعا هم اذا عندما ارسل عبد
السلام ابو بكر الى الى النيجر مع السلطان
السيد ابو بكر
وطبعا
وبالمناسبه حاليا نحن نتحدث عن رئيس غينيا
بيساو وهو رئيس دوله عضو في الاكواس يزور
نيجيريا وايضا هو ايضا جنرال عسكري وايضا
يساهم طبعا هو يحاول الذهاب الى النيجر
اذا الطريق الدبلوماسي مازال مفتوحا الذين
اصطفوا وراء ماكرون مثل مسعود وزير خارجيه
بازوم ومثل بازوم نفسه هم الذين يدعون الى
تدخل عسكري لا وصلت الفكره شكرا لك من دوز
دور في المانيا ادم جا الخبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه في الجابون قال قائد الحرس
الجمهوري الجنرال برس نجيما الذي سيؤدي
غدا اليمين الدستوريه رئيسا انتقاليا
للبلاد ان قرار حل المؤسسات وا امر مؤقت
هدفه اعاده تنظيمها لتصبح اكثر ديمقراطيه
وانسجاما مع المعايير الدوليه ووعد نجيما
بدستور جديد يلبي تطلعات الشعب الجابوني
وبقانون انتخابي جديد لكن دون تسرع على حد
وصفه
سنضع دستورا جديدا بمشاركه الجميع وسنعيد
الامور الى نصابها من اجل الانضباط
والنظام مع احترام الصلاحيات وحدودها وبعد
كتابه هذا الدستور سنضع قوانين وضوابط
انتخابيه ونذهب مباشره الى انتخابات ذات
مصداقيه حيث الخاسر يعترف بهزيمته ويهنئ
المترشحون بعضهم كما كان يحصل في السابق
هذا اذا اردنا توطيد
السلم اعلنت شرطه محافظه كركوك رفع حظر
تجوال في المدينه وعوده حركه المرور الى
طبيعتها بعد ازاله خيام المعتصمين
المنصوبه على الطريق الرابط بين اربيل
وكركوك وافادت مصادر محليه بفتح الطريق
الرئيسي وبدء بلديه كركوك رفع اثار
المواجهات التي شهدتها المدينه بين
مواطنين اكراد وعرب على خلفيه اخلاء مقر
عمليات كركوك من قبل القوات العراقيه
وتسليمه للحزب الكردستاني برئاسه مسعود
برزاني الذي كان يتهيا ل العوده الى كركوك
واسفرت اعمال العنف وفق قياده عمليات
كركوك عن مقتل اربعه اشخاص واصابه
15 هذا وقررت المحكمه الاتحاديه العليا في
العراق ايقاف تنفيذ امر رئيس الوزراء
بخصوص اخلاء مقر عمليات قياده كركوك ووفق
المحكمه فان قرارها يهدف الى حفظ الامن في
محافظه كركوك وتغليب الوحده
الوطنيه لحق في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء
على اهميه كركوك ونسال ضيف الحصاد عن
قراءته لمسار الاحداث
[موسيقى]
فيها اوردت وكاله انباء البحرين ان وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الي كوهين وصل الى
المنامه في زياره تستغرق يومين وان وزير
الخارجيه البحريني كان في استقباله فيما
قال بيان صادر عن الخارجيه الاسرائيليه نا
كوهين سيلتقي خلال الزياره مسؤولين
بحرينيين وسيقوم بتدشين افتتاح مقر
السفاره الاسرائيليه بشكل رسمي في المنامه
مع التوقيع على مذكرات تفاهم في مجالي
التجاره والاستثمارات المتبادله واشاد
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي بالترحاب الذي
قابله به وزير الخارجيه
البحريني افادت مصادر محليه في سوريا بان
اشتباكات بين مقاتلي العشائر العربيه وما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه امتدت الى
ريفي الرقه والحسكه وبث مقاتلوا العشائر
صورا قالوا انها لسيطرتهم على قريتي
الطرقي وتل الطويل بريف الحسكه اضافه الى
قريه غيره في ريف الرقه كما هاجموا نقطه
في بلده محيميد بريف دير الزور الغربي كما
بثوا صورا قالوا انها هجوم قرب بلده سلوك
بريف الرقه الشمالي كما اشتبكوا مع قوات
النظام السوري وقطعوا الطريق الدولي ام
اربعه على محور سجيرو جنوب تل الابيض وفي
التطورات ايضا ذكرت مصادر محليه ان مقاتلي
العشائر سيطروا على حاجز لقوات النظام
السوري وما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في ريف تل تمر شمال الحسكه بينما افاد
افادوا بمقتل مدنيين وجرح اخرين اثر قصف
شنته ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قرب
البصيره بريف دير الزوري العقيدات يلا
حيهم يلا حيهم الله
اكبر في الوقت نفسه قالت السفاره
الامريكيه في سوريا ان نائب مساع وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي وقائد العمليات
الامريكيه ضد تنظيم الدوله في سوريا
والعراق التقيا مع ما تسمى قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وزعماء القبائل في دير الزور
واتفقوا على اهميه معالجه مظالم سكان دير
الزور ومخاطر التدخل الخارجي في المنطقه
كما اكدوا على ضروره تجنب سقوط قتلى و
جرحى في صفوف المدنيين وشدد الجانب
الامريكي على اهميه الشراكه مع ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في جهود دحر
تنظيم
الدوله في المقابل نفى ابراهيم الهفل شيخ
قبيله العقيدات في سوريا وجود هدنه بين
العشائر العربيه وما تعرف بقوات سوريا
ديمقراطيه واكد في تسجيل صوتي منسوب له
بثته مواقع اعلاميه محليه استمرار القتال
بين الجانبين على حد
قوله قوات ابناء العشائر حيث تم تداول بين
الاعلام عن وجود هدنه بين قوات قسد وقوات
العشائر هذا الكلام عاري عن الصحه والقتال
نعلمكم
مستمر اما ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه فنوت بالاجتماع الذي وصفته
بالايجاب الذي عقد في شمال وشرق سوريا مع
نائب مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ايثن
جولدر وايضا قائد عمليه العزم الصلب
اللواء جويل فويل لمناقشه الاوضاع في دير
الزور وقالت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في بيان انها انهت تمشيط بلده
البصيره والجزء الاكبر من شحيل بريف دير
الزور وانها تتجه الى حسم العمليه في بلده
الذيبان وبحسب البيان اكدت ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه ان شيخ قبيله العقيدات
ابراهيم الهفل بات مطلوبا لها لتسببه في
اراقه دماء مقاتليها وتشريد المدنيين
وتخريب المؤسسات الخدميه المدنيه وفق
البيان
اذا المعارك تتسع رقعتها من دير الزور الى
الحسكه والرقه وحلب سياقات المشهد نتابعها
في التقرير
التالي محافظه دير الزور حيث يشق نهر
الفرات طريقه في اراضي سوريا قاسما
المحافظه ذات الغالبيه العربيه الى ضفتين
شرقيه وغربيه تسيطر ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه على الضفه الشماليه الشرقيه
لنهر الفرات في حين تتمركز قوات النظام
وفصائل مواليه لايران على الضفه الجنوبيه
الغربيه للنهر منذ نحو اسبوع تشتعل نيران
صراع في شمال شرق سوريا وتحديدا في دير
الزور يتقاتل حلفاء الامس العشائر
والقبائل العربيه السوريه وما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه ككره لهب تتسع رقعه
القتال شمال شرق سوريا لتحرق مناطق في ريف
في الرقه والحسكه وحلب وذلك مع انضمام
الاف المقاتلين من العشائر في ادلب وحلب
الى المواجهه فيما يشبه الفزعه العشائريه
اشتباكات عنيفه تدور بين الطرفين على محور
قريه الطويله بريف تل تمر ومحور قريه ام
عيشه شرق راس العين بالحسكه يقول مقاتلوا
العشائر العربيه انهم سيطروا على قريتي تل
الطويل والطرق بالحسكه وذلك بعد ساعات من
اعلانهم السيطره على قرى عرب كبير
والمحموديه وتل سيريا تل في ريف منبج شرق
حلب في المقابل تحشد ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مقاتليها وتدفع بتعزيزات
كبيره الى ريف دير الزور وتحكم هذه القوات
ذات الغالبيه الكرديه سيطرتها على مدينتي
البصيره وال شحيل بعد انسحاب مقاتلي
العشائر العربيه منهما خلافات مستتره على
النفوذ وامتعاض العشائر العربيه من قبضه
ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه المهيمنه
على دير الزور اسباب يعزو اليها مقاتل
العشائر اشتعال القتال وان كانت نيران
الحرب تحرق سوريا فان دخانها لا محاله
يتجاوز حدودها من بعيد تراقب واشنطن
بصفتها قائده التحالف الدولي القتال شمال
شرق سوريا وتدعو المتقاتلين الى الوقف
الفوري للاشتباكات والعوده الى خندق الحرب
ضد تنظيم الدوله فمن يتحاربون كانوا قبل
بض اعوام راس حربه في القضاء على نفوذ
تنظيم الدوله وانتزاع اخر معاقله اقصى دير
الزور اما تركيا فهي معنيه باي حرب تكون
الوحدات الكرديه طرفا فيها فقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تتشكل غالبيتها من وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه الجناح العسكري لحزب
الاتحاد الوطني وهو وفق انقره الامتداد
السوري لحزب العمال الكردستاني الذي تصنفه
تركيا ودول اخرى تنظيما ارها هايا موقف
تركيا هذا كفيل لاي يشير مع اي الفريقين
يصطف الجار الشمالي
لسوريا انضم الينا من غازي عنت سعد الشارع
الكاتب والباحث السياسي سيد سعد مرحبا بك
معنا بالنظر الى حاله المعارك هناك
وطبيعه التركيبه والتحالفات
والتشابكات هل ما يجري على الارض هي
معادله
صفريه لصالح جهه وطرف واحد ام يمكن الحديث
عن عوده العلاقات مره اخرى بين
الطرفين يعني لا اعتقد ان هذه المعارك سوف
تذهب الى حسم مباشر الى احد الطرفين السبب
في ذلك حقيقه هو وجود القوات الامريكيه
امريكا لا تريد ان تظهر انها في موقف
احراج نظرا لانها هي الداعم الاساسي لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه او ما يسمى بقصد في هذه
المنطقه لذلك من مهام الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وين اشارت حقيقه هي في بيانها
او في تصريحات متعدده ان مهمتها الاساسيه
في هذه المنطقه هو قتال الارهاب المتمثل
بتنظيم داعش لكن عليها التزامات بعدم خلق
اي اشكاليات اجتماعيه او عسكريه او امنيه
لذلك هي مطالبه واعتقد انها لن تسمح يعني
زمنيا باكثر من ذلك الا بايجاد حل تدرك
يعني مجتمعات هذه المنطقه ان اي حاله صراح
صراع مفتوح هي ربما تودي الى معركه طويله
الامد بين مكونات هذه المنطقه لذلك الان
جميع المطالب من جميع الاطراف هي ربما
تنحصر بالوضع الاجتماعي بالوضع العسكري
بالوضع ال الخدمي مطالب ابناء القبائل
والعشائر ال 14 مطلب التي تم تداوله وهي
كانت واضحه بان يكون لهم استقلاليه في
القياده العسكريه والقياده الاداريه وهذا
اعتقد المطلب هو لا تستطيع تطبيقه قسد قسد
تطرح نفسها انها هي القوه العسكريه
الوحيده الموجوده في هذه المنطقه وايضا
ادارتها وما تسمى بالاداره الذاتيه هو شكل
الحوكمه الوحيد الموجود في هذه المنطقه
لذلك لا اعت اعتقد انها تسمح بتطبيق هذه
بتطبيق هذه الشروط لان هذا الموضوع لا
يعني فقط خرج هذه المنطقه عن ايديها ايضا
ان يكون هناك مطالب سيد سيد سعد وهنا تاتي
وساطه الولايات المتحده ولقاء نائب مساعد
وزير الخارجيه وايضا قائد عمليه العزم
الصلب ايضا لمحاربه تنظيم الدوله في
العراق وسوريا مع الطرفين هل بامكانها ان
تعطي هذه المطالب للعشائر وان ايضا ترضي
الجانب
الكردي او جانب مكون قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه يعني هي تستطيع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بحكم نفوذها وقوتها في
هذه المنطقه ان توجد حل ربما يكون يرضي
الطرفين الى حد ما هي لا اعتقد انها حتى
هي لا تسمح ب بان تاخذ محافظه دير الزور
او منطقه دير الزور استقلاليتها لكن يمكن
ان تعطى هنا يعني خصوصيه معينه اساسا هي
مطالب مطالب ابناء هذه المنطقه في بدايه
الامور هي لم تكن كبيره هي كانت تتعلق
باشكال مع ذاته مجلس دير الزور العسكري
الذي هو يتشكل من ابناء هذه المنطقه بتسلط
بعض قيادات ما يسمى بالكادر قيادات حزب
العمال الكردستاني على هذه المنطقه بعدم
اعطاء هذه المنطقه ما تستحقه هذه المنطقه
التي تعد هي الخزان الاقتصادي الاساسي
لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه فيها فيها اهم
حقول النفط في سوريا مع حقل العمر النفطي
واهم معامل الغاز في سوريا معمل غاز
كونيكو لذلك لا اعتقد ان امريكا تريد ان
تذهب هذه المنطقه الى الى فوضه نظرا لوجود
اطراف جدا يعني متحكمه ايضا ببعض جوانب
العمل العسكري والامني مثل تنظيم داعش
الذي يتواجد في جنوب محافظه الحسكه ويتصل
الى الحدود السوريه العراقيه وايضا ايران
المتواجده في سبع قر داخل هذه المنطقه
لذلك اعتقد ان امريكا سوف تذهب في الفتره
القادمه او في الساعات القادمه لايجاد حل
مرضي بين الطرفين شكرا لك من غازي عنتاب
سعد الشارع الكاتب والباحث
السياسي
[موسيقى]
مواجهات وحظر للتجوال رفع لاحقا ودخول
المحكمه الاتحاديه العليا على الخط فما
الذي يحدث في كركوك تمتد كركوك على مساحه
10000 ر مربع وتبعد عن بغداد نحو 250
كيلومترا ويقدر عدد سكانها بنحو مليون
ونصف المليون نسمه بين كرد وعرب وتركمان
وقوميات اخرى كركوك محافظه غنيه بالنفط
وقع تقع بين اقليم كردستان العراق الذي
يتمتع بالحكم الذاتي والمناطق التي تسيطر
عليها الحكومه المركزيه وتشير التقديرات
الى ان هذه المحافظه الواقعه في شمال
العراق تنتج 40% من اجمال النفط العراقي و
70% من الغاز الطبيعي الذي ينتجه العراق
بوجه عام وبسبب موقعها الجغرافي وثرائها
الاقتصادي ظلت المحافظه منذ فتره مبكره من
تاريخ العراق الحديث منطقه نزاع وتوتر بين
بغداد واربيل ووضعت كركوك بموجب الماده
140 من دستور العراق الذي اقر في ال من
اكتوبر 2005 ضمن ما تسمى بالمناطق
المتنازع عليها بين السلطه المركزيه في
بغداد واقليم كردستان العراق امس السبت
شهدت كركوك التي يقطنها عرب واكراد
وتركمان مظاهرات تخللتها اشتباكات بين
متظاهرين اكراد من جهه ومشاركين في اعتصام
من العرب والتركمان من جهه اخرى فما الذي
فما هو مسار الاحداث وما الذي جرى هناك
يوم الاثنين نظم محتاجون من القوميتين
العربيه والتركمان اعتصاما قرب المقر
العام لقوات الامن العراقيه في محافظه
كركوك اثر امر رئيس الوزراء
العراقي بتسليم هذا المقر الى الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الذي سبق ان شغل
هذا الموقع واحتشد المتظاهرون الاكراد امس
السبت في نهايه فتره بعد الظهر وحاولوا
الوصول الى هذا المقر الامر الذي ادى الى
تدهر الوضع بشكل سريع صباح اليوم الاحد
اكد قائد عمليات كركوك الفريق ركن جبار
نعيمه طائي ان المقر تحت سيطره الجيش
العراقي قراءه اكثر في ابعاد هذا النزاع
والصراع ينضم الينا من بغداد السيد هاني
عاشور الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي سيد هاني
عاشور مرحبا بك معنا اذا هي ساحه للنزاع
بانقسامات
مجتمعيه
بمكوناتها وهويات الفرعيه
وجذورها التاريخيه ايضا تتداخل مع تنافسيه
سياسيه بالنظر الى كل هذه التعقيدات في
كركوك هل هذا هذه جوله من النزاعات بين
هذه
المكونات ام يعني سنشهد المزيد فيما
بعد
شكرا لكم بدايه هذه جوله من
جولات حقيقه ازمه تتجدد والحلول وقتيه ولا
يوجد هناك حل ثابت منذ الدستور العراقي في
2005 واقرار هذا الدستور كان هناك فقره
الماده 140 التي تتناول قضيه المناطق
المتنازع عليها واعتبرت مناطق من كركوك
متنازع عليها على ان تحل هذه الازمه من
خلال اجراء استفتاء لسكان هذه المنطقه
ومناطق اخرى طبعا ويقرر السكان الى اي طرف
يحاولون الانتماء هذه ليست فقط الازمه في
كركوك وان كانت هناك اقل ولكن لان كركوك
مدينه غنيه بالثروات النفطيه وتشكل عنصر
مهم من الاقتصاد العراقي نجدها دائما
تتوقد فيها المشاكل حتى انتخابات مجالس
المحافظات التي كانت تجري كل اربع سنوات
لم تجري في كركوك لعده دورات انتخابيه
لذلك هذه الازمه كانت متوقعه متوقعه مع
اقترابنا من موعد انتخابات مجلس المحافظات
الذي سيكون في نهايه العام المقبل هل هي
حسابات خاطئه منقبل الحكومه العراقيه سيد
هاني هل هي خطا في حسابات رئاسه الوزراء
العراقيه ام يعني بالاضافه الى جمله
العوامل الاخرى التي
ذكرتها ادت الى مثل هذا المشهد الذي
شهدناه قبل ايام في كركوك ا
ماذا بكل تاكيد قضيه نقل المقر
ومجيء الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
والعوده الى مقره اثار حفيظه سكان هذه
المنطقه الذين كانوا يعتبرون قياده
العمليات المشتركه في كركوك هي حاميه لهم
منذ عام
2017 حتى الان اي بعد الاستفتاء وجاءت
القوات العراقيه واتخذت هذا المقر بعد
الاستفتاء على استقلال اقليم كردستان
والذي لم يتم وتصاعد فيه الموقف يبدو ان
قضيه تشكيل الحكومه العراقيه والازمه التي
وقعت فيها فرضت على الاطراف اتفاقات هذه
الاتفاقات كان من ضمنها ان يعود الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الى كركوك ان تعود
قوات من البيش مر الى كركوك لذلك الاهالي
رفضوا ذلك لانهم منذ ست سنوات تقريبا منذ
خروج البيش مرقه ومنذ خروج الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني
واقترابهم وامل في بان انتخابات مجالس
المحافظات المقبله بعد حل المجالس ستعطيهم
فرصه اكبر للتمثيل في محافظتهم كعرب
وتركمان اضافه الى الكرد تسبب في هذه
الازمه حقيقه مقر القياده هو كان عود ثقاب
المشكله اكبر من ذلك بكثير من هذه الاسباب
سبب قانون النفط
والغاز الموجود والذي لم يقر ل
حتى هذه اللحظه وسبب كثير من المشاكل شكرا
جزيلا لك من بغداد هاني عاشور الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي شكرا على المشاركه
[موسيقى]
معنا
ارقام لافته فقد بلغ عدد طالبي اللجوء
الذين يعبرون قناه المانش على متن قوارب
صغيره من شمال فرنسا الى بريطانيا بلغ
مستوى قياسيا يوميا جديدا في العام
20023 فامس السبت فقط عبر
872 طالب لجوء على متن 15 قاربا احدى اكثر
القنوات ازدحاما في العالم ولطالما كان
هذا الطريق محفوفا بالمخاطر بحيث انقلبت
قوارب كثيره وغرق عشرات في مياه القناه
خلال العقد الماضي واجمالا عبر اكثر من
100 الف طالب لجوء قناه المانش منذ بدء
بريطانيا احصاء الوافدين في عام
2018 هي ارقام تعني بانه بالرغم من مخاطر
رحلات الهجره القيود والاجراءات المشدده
التي تنتظر طالبي اللجوء ان وصلوا بسلام
يواصل كثيرون المغامره هربا من اوضاع صعبه
بحثا عن حياه افضل ختام الحصاد شكرا لكم
على المتابعه ودمتم
[موسيقى]
بخير
ا